Welcome to our session on what is
integration platform as a service
otherwise known as iPass and what makes
this as a service unique is really the
integration platform piece of it so
today we're going to talk about the why
the how and the what of it but before we
get into that you may be wondering why
iPass is even relevant to you so let's
start with a simple analogy like many of
you I have a phone with potentially
hundreds of different apps on it and I
probably only use five to ten on any
given day
you can translate this experience to
your organization maybe there's only
five to ten different apps or systems
that you're using on a day-to-day but if
you think about the entire organization
as a whole there's potentially thousands
of different or applications that need
to be managed across your entire
organization this can get really
overwhelming to be able to effectively
manage and monitor that's where iPass
comes into the picture and leads us into
the why if you consider the different
types of systems that you might have
within your company they tend to look
something like this B2B
SAS applications
devices
data
and on-premise systems
now traditionally you would see a lot of
businesses wanting to be able to
leverage the data across many of these
different types of systems so they'd
build these integration points between
each of these but going back and forth
you can see how this can quickly get
overwhelming having to manage and
monitor all of the different types of
connections that are happening within
the organization and there's certainly
no reusability coming into the play
that's where iPass comes in it sits
right at the top of all of this and
serves as a management layer for being
able to interact and integrate with all
of these different types of systems more
effectively and more efficiently for you
and your business
so let's see how we can put this into
play with a simple example
over to the how
here we have Taylor Taylor is a very
successful sales agent selling laptops
to her customers and she's already
secured a new customer opportunity
traditionally all of her customer
information is stored in the CRM
and what Taylor needs to do is to be
able to take all of that data and put it
into her quoting system so that she can
send a quote to this customer
now if you look at traditional methods
for this Taylor would have to go into
her CRM copy down the fields and then
re-input them into the quoting system an
easy way for manual errors to pop up
with mistyping or typos and things like
that or maybe it's just a little bit
more sophisticated and she's able to
download a spreadsheet from her CRM and
then re-upload that into the quoting
system but you might see more issues
where fields are being mismapped between
the different systems and this is also
just an extra tedious step within the
process
again this is where iPads can make the
whole entire process more efficient by
sitting right between these two
applications and building an integration
between both of them rather than
requiring tailored to serve as the
middleman
this means as soon as she starts typing
the customer's name within the quoting
system it could populate all of the
corresponding data for her automatically
but the best part about iPads is this
isn't the end of where you're able to
integrate and bring different data and
systems together she can also add in
things like her payment platform
so that the customer can immediately
respond to the quote by providing
payment or maybe she also wants to
integrate with her procurement system so
the order can be sent out for delivery
right away this can all be managed
through her iPads and building these
different Integrations between the whole
process
this is a larger example within the
company but there might be use cases
that she wants to bring to her team
specifically
a great example of this is if she has a
new mission to be able to notify her
team whenever a lead is received so she
could go into Salesforce
and set up an integration with her iPads
that sends a message in slack to her
team every time a new lead is received
this is part of the build piece of it
Taylor is able to build this integration
between these two different systems how
is she able to do that leveraging
connection points
often you'll see with common SAS
applications like Salesforce and slack
there are out of the box connectors that
make these connections even faster for
her to be able to use
but an added piece of this might be she
only wants to notify her team when it's
qualified leads
so she needs to make sure that the data
that's being received within here is
only alerting when it's a qualified lead
that's where the transform piece comes
in where she is able to transform the
data that's flowing between these
systems so that whenever she gets a
notification to her team it's only of
the most qualified caliber of potential
customers the last bit really starts to
look at our manage where should be able
to oversee this entire process and
ensure that it's operating without any
errors or efficient as efficiently as
possible
that was our how so let's get in just a
little bit deeper to the what of it
here we were just taking an example
where Taylor was able to build this
different integration flows now with the
build piece you'll generally see tooling
like no code authoring
with high code options available as well
but that really facilitates building
these types of integration flow patterns
more easily by any type of user
the next piece is really around connect
this is where we're able to get into
things like the connectors we talked
about
which serve as pre-built out of the box
connection points with common SAS
applications so you only have to provide
your credentials to get started this
also includes things like templates
which might be the full pattern
pre-built for the user
in the industry these are commonly
called Pips
the next piece is really around
transform here's where we saw we were
able to transform specific types of data
but it also applies to AI
Transformations which could provide help
with mapping fields or transforming
different types of formulas and
providing those for you more effectively
the last bit is around manage and here
this can apply to a lot of things as
well but you typically see it applying
in terms of observability
and monitoring
to make sure that you're able to
troubleshoot and debug all of your
processes across the business and
maintain all of your integration points
excellent well hopefully through these
examples you are able to see why
integration platform as a service is so
pivotal to any business looking to
transform digitally thank you so much
for your time
thank you if you liked this video and
want to see more like it please like And
subscribe if you have questions please
drop them in the comments below